5 25 on your monday morning hey there is
a double whammy now of lane restrictions
and street closures under the 95 515. so
desert inn shut down just east of
sandhill halfway around the curve to
land there's just after midnight this
one going to stay that way through the
start of the weekend now access to local
businesses is still open they're
demolishing the freeways northbound side
following the earlier breakdown and
rebuilding of the southbound section now
eastern well it hasn't been reopened but
a few days from the most recent closure
for bridge demolition but it's about to
shut down again starting at six tomorrow
morning scheduled to run until next
monday evening crews going to start the
rebuilding of the bridge that they just
took down also numerous ramp closures
lane restrictions at both eastern and
between boulder highway and flamingo
just follow the cones you should be okay
meanwhile the
i515project.com website does a great job
of keeping you updated on all the
construction work but we've got a link
to that and all of our stories on
eightnewsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com